on this episode we hang out in New York
City and I keep it tight and firm
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 127 of
the ask gary vee show beautiful day here
in new york city kind a little muggy
humid india you like it
really excited about doing the show got
a shootout to Oklahoma City to to go
give a speech and do some consulting for
a client of mine I know everybody who
lives in Oklahoma City is gonna be like
hey Gary I'm flying in I'm flying out
I'm sorry but hopefully I'll see you in
the streets a little high five action we
are in the streets of New York City
the rugged Upper East Side and I'm
excited it is so India let's get into
that show good job not bad a little
false start when you got in there good
job
alright let's do it Josh asks what is
the number one thing that keeps good
leaders from becoming great the number
one thing that keeps good leaders from
becoming great very good question maybe
a great question from Josh I think
there's a couple things I think money I
think I think money is a funny way to
happen a leader they're driven by that I
think that emotional skill sets its you
know to be great at something you have
to over index you just have to you have
to be able to be great at it I mean you
could be a good basketball player you
could be a great basketball player and a
lot of that has to do with DNA and so I
think a lot of natural leadership skills
you know for me the reason I aspire to
be a great leader is actually focus on
one variable and I want everybody to
hear this and it's a very sneaky pillar
of my life success which is what I think
about you India or you d-roc or anybody
that uh that I jam with in my world
startups companies that I'm when I go to
Oklahoma City the client I'm trying to
provide 51
the value I really believe that and and
not because I'm this great human being
because I think it's leverage I think
that if Dirac feels that I'm slightly
providing more value to him that he's
providing to me financially upside in
the future mentorship whatever it may be
that that's going to make me a great
leader
hey it's how he feels about me and B
it's going to focus me on always trying
to one-up the next person and when
you're a leader one up and comes in many
forms I'm gonna continue to show you
angles that you haven't seen about
yourself
right I'm going to continue to challenge
you financially compensate you give you
opportunities bring you two things one
upping trying to provide more value to
the other person and and I think that uh
I think a lot of great leaders are a lot
of good leaders are 8024 themselves I
think extremely good leaders are 5050 I
think great leaders start to go to the
5149 direction Cindy asks what are your
thoughts about the subscription box
business model trend change in behavior
sustainable long term Cindy I think I
think it's a great question I'm very
bullish on it I mean I don't know if you
know that you're talking to the person
that wrote one of the first two checks
into Birchbox
angel investor in barkbox in my own fund
vayner/rse we think you baited only
three companies brave and an incredible
company resi an incredible company and
our third incredible company is faith
box I really believe in it I don't know
if it's a change in behavior remember
there was like six you guys are young
old-timers remember there's like a
Columbia house music subscription thing
like subscription models have existed
forever what's that that pear company
David and Harry
carrying David's like like you know
basket of the month like wine of the
month clubs I came from it's not a
change I think that it's always been
something that we as consumers want
which is I'll pay one time just haven't
show up I actually think there's way
more upside in it I don't I think that
there's way more to go and I think the
brands a lot barkbox that get into the
lifestyle business into the media
business have a real play and so I'm
very bullish on it I do not think it's a
fad it's clearly not a bad because of
the month clubs have existed for a long
long time
Shan asks what is the best way a college
student can make supplementary income
that's a tough question I don't love
this question to be honest with you I I
think that there's seventeen thousand
ways to make supplementary income you
can babysit you can collect hands on the
street and return it for deposits you go
garage saling and flip it you can go to
all the freelance sites in the world and
and do your thing if you can design or
video you can become an uber driver you
can mow [ __ ] lawns like like what
kind of question is that
India I think the answer to that
question is the way you make
supplemental income is to put in work
you can quit school too but I mean like
that question stinks it's a stinky
question and I'm not I'm sorry I know
you watch a show I love you I love you
I'm there's a straight tough love like
it's a mentality thing not a tactical
thing there's a billion ways to make
money we're in goddamn America 99 for if
you're not 98 percent of the countries
in the world you can make money like but
we're gonna cost
shrimp in club so that's interesting I'm
more like a champagne kind of thing yeah
Perth champagne club asks what are your
goals for vaynermedia is there an end
game there is an end game I want to
build the greatest marketing company of
all time right and I want to build the
greatest marketing company of all time
that is an evergreen business for me
that I can deploy all my future
activities around aka when I owned the
New York Jets vaynermedia will be the
marketing company that redesigns the
logo that does the marketing plan to
take more of the New York market share
from the Giants back to the Jets to sell
tickets while everybody's living in a
virtual reality world and feel like
they're playing as why would I go in
this stadium so yeah I want to build it
and it was one of the great I think will
end up being one of the great pillars of
my business career the decision four
years ago really six years ago but
really four years ago to build an agency
that scales my skill set to build
infrastructure around me to then enhance
all my future take one step backwards
because that's what vaynermedia was to
build a client service business that was
taking away from all my other behavior
one step backwards for two steps forward
gear on if you slow
no fun press asks what are the daily
decisions you've stopped making or put
on autopilot in order to maximize your
brainpower for the day that's a great
question Thank You India and no fun
press I'm gonna blow your faces off
almost all of them
whoa
almost all of them and what I mean by
that is I fundamentally believe that I
recognized for me that 99% of things
don't matter I mean you guys roll with
me how many you know you know right like
what I don't care I'm fine
like like think about the lack of
micromanaging I do
the lack of like like being weird of
like this that like like you know like
literally the only micromanaging I ever
did was like when I would make Zack like
you know Photoshop out my double chin
during the fat years I mean like you
know like I really really really believe
that most things don't matter
and so what I do is I you know put
people in positions to succeed I
recognize look I do I do believe that
most people that do things for me or
with me especially their tasks that I
can do don't do them as well as I do I'm
like every other person with ego and
skills and all that the problem is I
recognize I can't do them all you know
it's about how you look at them do you
rock and I had an interesting
conversation the other day on a
different subject but it was like you
can look at this or you can look at this
right and that's how I look at it I
could do all these 29 things at an 11 or
I can outsource that and let all of them
be eights and sevens and sixes and fives
because they don't mean that much and I
could focus on whatever's left for me
and do it at a 37 and so or an 11 just
to make the analogy proper so I think
most things don't matter I go with my
intuition to focus on what I should be
doing
that's it that's it i-i've been able to
level up in my career by leaving my ego
at the door and recognizing that other
people hip could do it better and if
they don't do it better that their eight
is as good as my eleven because the end
result of the marketplace judging is an
alien Elevens the same goddamn thing and
my time and energy can be deployed
against something bigger Wow optically
back to the prior question we'll focus
on something like vaynermedia where
holistically people thought a waste of
my time
I knew what my 25-year 40-year strategy
was and so that's a scoop in yeah
there's a good day here in in the
streets it's good to see the core team
in place me in the end Iraq all those
other characters they can come and go
question of the day what is your
favorite thing about New York City
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering podcasts alert outside of New
York City decided to give you a little
extra podcast love and here we go sorry